all right rowan
romano where are you from where do you
grow up i'm from middletown connecticut
i was born in middletown connecticut
i've spent a lot of time in new haven i
went to school in new haven lived there
for the most of the pandemic
an apartment but i was born and
grew up in middletown connecticut which
is
a couple hours from new york city yeah
it's only a couple hours from new york
city it's like i've i've been here a lot
but it's like a just kind of a central
connecticut town because it's got like
wesleyan but i've
wesley in the the liberal arts school
and
it's got a very
focused community of
of people that have come from like it
was a it was like an immigration hub
back
in the past so we have a lot of like
cultural restaurants and things that i
like kind of took for granted and i now
miss here even though i'm in another
huge cultural hub
and tell me about your family you had
both mom and dad growing up yeah both my
mom and dad my mom and dad are together
i've got three sisters um my mom and dad
both are theater artists
have been as long as i can remember they
my dad runs like a community theater
company that kind of
specializes in like
uh arts programming for like the for
everyone so they bust kids after school
and stuff for all sorts of arts and
theater programming
and my they also run like a outdoor
shakespeare company that went on for
about like 12 years and you're going to
school for drama at nyu and i'm going to
school for yeah for drama at nyu
in the experimental theater wing how old
are you i'm 19 i'll be 20 in july in the
summer
i
yeah
i'm enjoying it i'm i'm loving it so far
like
new york city i i'm absolutely loving
new york city it's kind of with the
place that i
already feel like i need to be which is
i guess probably how a lot of nyu
students feel except for the ones who
very much don't but uh
being here i already don't want to leave
and i already want to be here forever
yeah coming from a small town in
connecticut a smaller town in
connecticut yeah to new york city it's
got to be exciting yeah no constant and
for me
i really function on like a
consistent schedule always having
something and being here made the mix of
time pass differently time here i think
just passes differently in general but
there's always something happening and
then when i get to the evening it feels
like time just
accelerates like the time between like
11 and 3 a.m in new york city is like
times five i feel like no matter what
you're doing
yeah definitely back to your childhood
how was your childhood growing up well
my
i like i said i did a lot of theater i
was actually homeschooled for
most of my childhood after kindergarten
i like had a
i just had a
time in kindergarten where i wanted to
leave like i vocalized my parents when i
was like five that i just didn't want to
be in
the environment of school i i really
don't know
i don't have a specific event that like
led me to that decision but i just knew
that school sucked i knew that and they
like they like my older sisters i have
two older sisters who are like 10 years
older than me they were went to public
school for the entirety of their
academic careers but i
my parents decided with me that i
vocalized it when i was five and i was
homeschooled until for the next three
years
and then fourth grade i kind of was like
you know what i'm gonna go back i wanna
try it out and for fourth and fifth
grade i went back to elementary school
and then decided again i don't like this
i'm gonna go and i was homeschooled for
middle school
and then in high school i auditioned for
a arts magnet school in new haven
what kind of kid were you in high school
i was i you know i
i was obviously a theater kid which you
know i did a lot of theater but i
i ended up having
friends who
are i'm still really close with a lot of
the friends i was in high school i still
like hold very close because i have
experienced a lot of things with them
went through a lot of like i had two
friends in high school who were
like sent to
like recovery programs in utah which is
kind of like a classic story of like
having your parents find out about some
kind of like usually like drug use of
some sort and
be like
we can't deal with this
there's this industry of people who
deal with this
and they
and then the kids are kind of swifted
away in the middle of the night were
drugs a thing even in connecticut yeah
yeah i mean i wasn't guys everywhere in
this country it seems no yeah definitely
definitely here in washington square
park it's oh yeah it's
definitely absolutely and connecticut
was
i was
i was around like there was a lot of
kind of separated out communities of
like different drugs i was only ever
in high school i only ever really smoked
weed and
tried psychedelics i never got into like
pills and stuff but a lot of people that
i knew
were and that's kind of what happened to
my two friends who went to utah their
parents like found out and like freaked
out and
you know paid a bunch of money to have
them sent off and they were gone for
like nine months with like no contact
with them one of them was gone for over
a year and it was gone for about nine
months
and
it was kind of
like traumatic for me in a certain way
because like it was just like a friend
who disappeared with literally no
warning like
like actually zero warning like they
were just taken away and like without
their choice like someone just showed up
to their house and they were like you're
coming with us the family was trying to
fix the problem yeah yeah
and
when they got back
they like they're absolutely the same
people but like they're they both kind
of processed it in very different ways
one of them i'm really not close to
anymore one of them i'm still very close
with
and the one who i'm still close with i
think has really processed that
experience very differently
at first they
felt like they were just kind of
escaping this like traumatic situation
but then they kind of talked about how
they'd
like ingrained a lot of
really like harmful thought patterns
into themselves that they
had to like consciously break apart
after the first few months of being back
in like
regular society around people who were
like connected to social media and all
this stuff that they just hadn't had any
access to for a long time
and they just kept coming up with all
these things that they were like i
don't actually believe this but i have
like a visceral reaction to
all of these things
and yeah you know the i think the stuff
out in utah at least the place that he
was at it was some very
not a great thing to do to a like a
struggling teenager
especially because you know they're kind
of a lot of them are like forcing their
religious agenda onto
them but
uh
they definitely i think also took
positive things from it like i think
there was
there was definitely some
very conscious personal growth
that came from that and they're doing
well now which is good like
they're not like really struggling
they're not like having issues with
drugs and even before like it's not like
they were really
like
having like a really bad time with
addiction it was the family was probably
just trying to nip it in the bud yeah
and in a way they it might have been a
good like thing for him like he probably
didn't need to
have a
some kind of intervention at that point
but it's such a dangerous problem yeah
the family probably took the right yeah
maybe made the right move to just stop
this yeah rather than letting you get
out of hand yeah
yeah it's a big problem in our country
it is it really is
like now you're going to college at nyu
do you see drug use oh yeah i i've
i've had my my share of like
wacky experiences here like
uh just
i personally have been
like basically
just smoking weed i guess that's like a
very see-through i've like
smoked weed kind of habitually as like a
little bit of a self-medication thing
for like
since i was a sophomore in high school
and it's just part of my
my uh existence at this point but
um
that's what i've stayed to myself but
i've definitely been around people
who are
like
very inexperienced with
drugs experiencing it for the first time
and who i had very little relation to
and had just met and it's like
you know that's what happens at colleges
but it's being around it on a first hand
perspective is really
interesting because i i like worry for
these people in certain ways like
they're not exactly
like entering into this world in the
most
safe of avenues but
i can't really do anything to help them
at this point
you're young just keep in mind that it's
easier for you to get taken down by them
than for you to build them up fix you
know fix the problem and build them up
what's more likely to happen is you'll
get taken down
so it's a it's a it's a tricky problem
it is yeah you're gonna more likely
you'll end up enabling in your effort to
help then you will end up helping so
yeah you have friends here in new york
city i do i've got so your friends are
currently new friends you've made since
you've moved here or friends you had
since living in connecticut so i've had
i've made a lot of new friends but like
my closest friend is uh
someone from my town middletown who i've
like known my entire life since i was
born like our friend our our moms met in
the same breastfeeding club
and so we've known each other since like
the womb and i hang out with him every
day which is kind of weird in like a
environment where i'm interacting he's
in new york city now he's also at uh at
tisch drama oh that's great so yeah that
helps a lot having having a great friend
with you absolutely it's like something
else i'm very grateful for
so what about what about women
i i mean i don't know i've been in a few
relationships
i
because my viewers are gonna ask
they're gonna ask well i'm you're
particularly handsome so i'm sure you'll
get that i would say i would say i'm i'm
pansexual so i'm not only
attracted to women but anyone who i find
attractive i
i i assume you were straight i'm sorry
that's that's fine a lot of people do
but i i'm not but
uh
i i have only had extended relationships
with women but i
um
i love women i'll say that i all my i
have three sisters so most of my and
most of my friends are women
yeah
good way to handle it yeah the world has
changed a lot it has yes how do you feel
about new york city it's exciting right
oh it's incredibly exciting like the
amount of art and music that i want to
like i it's very hard not to spend all
of my money actually i already have
spent all of my money on show tickets
and like going to like underground i'm
trying to find more i was really into
connecticut into like diy
shows and just getting involved with
artists who were trying to create here
in new york you've got all you could do
yeah everything all you could take in
everything yeah like too much to
possibly sort it out and figure out what
is and and like finding the things that
are really interesting to me are like
the things that nobody knows about which
is you have to find them
yourself because nobody knows about them
right and yeah but that's what new york
new york city is so great for yeah you
can always find something there's always
there's something for everybody here and
the more you can get into that the more
the less likely you'll end up getting
into other things yeah yeah they can be
more destructive yeah
i
it um
it's one of the like it's because like
it's such a populated city and
especially like a densely populated city
and
it i
i lived in in sri lanka for five months
when i was
12
with my parents doing like they were on
a theater grant from the from like the
american embassy and i live in colombo
which is like more densely populated
than here and
it's
it's like a very it's such a
dramatically different
city experience and
like
the the the the amount that i like take
for granted the infrastructure of new
york city and like american cities in
general
are just like a standard of
infrastructure that might be like
outdated in a certain sense and there's
like a lot of
there's like a lot of nyu students who
kind of look at it and are like oh new
york is so like dirty and like uh which
i think is just kind of
looking at it like a weird zoo but uh
it's it's it's an incredibly like
safe and
like um
what's the word
just there's a million words from new
york city there is a million words from
new york city yeah but it's it's
stimulating it's it's
it's it's so
i i used especially when i was younger
in my career as a photographer
i found it to be the most motivating
place i could ever go
because all the great photographers
lived here
most of them
and it's just such a stimulating
motivating place and for for an actor as
well it's got to be a single yeah
absolutely no the amount of
conversations and even just places that
i've seen that have made me
want to write monologues or made me want
to like very inspire a very inspiring
place to be unbelievable and just the
amount of parks the amount of like
public parks
like i i love um
i've been walking down to hudson river
park and just looking out at the water
and like the in central park is kind of
my only access to like
nature because i've been really really
amazing it's not it's not a nature here
but it's still a beautiful beautiful
city oh it's absolutely beautiful but
yeah no that is like i miss like the
the feeling of being in the woods which
is something that i would you're
in a lot in connecticut
yeah you have to get back to connecticut
for that yeah no but it's also pretty
easy to do that it's yeah
your family sounded pretty solid
yeah my family i appreciate my family a
lot like and giving me access to the
things
that i
have had access to like living in out of
the country living in sri lanka
um
and going to nyu like is something that
i would not be able to do if my parents
weren't supportive of me
like i mean it's not even like they can
pay for it and i didn't get like an
incredible scholarship like definitely
going into debt for this
arts degree that is not in any way sure
to give make me any money
but uh they're supportive of me in that
which is like
something that a lot of people do not
have at all and
like yeah i know gratitude is something
that i have been
overwhelmed with since i've gotten here
in every way like for your family for my
family for just like there's just a
situation that i'm in now or for your
family yeah yeah yeah it sounds like
you were very loved by your family and
that that shows in your mental state and
your
your ability to
enjoy your life and have fun yeah i
i
i definitely like last year was like a a
struggle for me in terms of like keeping
things going because of just the way
the the
it was a struggle for a lot of people in
terms of the pandemic but i like i said
i was i had an apartment for like the
entirety of the gap year that i took
with a few friends and i was just
working
and i really didn't end up being able to
do as much
and as many like active things as i
wanted to do i really just spent all of
my time
working and paying rent and
the whole world was kind of frozen yeah
it was it was frozen and
that led to a lot of just
uh
like just just a rough time for me
mentally over the whole year but ever
since i've been here and kind of picking
up since the beginning of this summer
because i i worked as like a um
[Music]
and a teacher for for kids between like
ages of 8 and 15
doing art stuff that it i put me back
into this space that was like
just discovery and
and
art of course like i always come back to
art for me but discovery and
and like social interaction leading to
the wheel turning forward that was just
it's put me it's completely changed like
the way that i'm
thinking about the future mainly i think
since this beginning of this would you
like to do in the future
well i wanted what's your dream my dream
i really i want to be
a i want to do theater but i want to be
able to blend it with everything with
with other forms of art i also do music
so i really want to be able to also
maintain
music in my future but i also
am interested in like very
community-based
theater
like um
i don't know if you're familiar with the
theater artist augusto belal but he has
this
this whole theater practice called
theater of the oppressed it's kind of
based around
the idea that like if you want to tell a
story of a group of people or a plight
of anybody or any kind of if you want to
tell any kind of story the best way to
do it is doing it with the people who
are experiencing it and going into the
communities that are experiencing
certain things and
creating like theater with those people
themselves even if they're not have no
experience doing theater and that's
something that like inspires me because
it really it really is true like
theater as a medium can be used
with people who have no experience doing
it to create like amazing
amazing
messages and tell stories that
illuminate
people's experiences
and that is really what i want to do
like i
i don't
nothing that i have thought about in my
future is really a plan to uh
well you're 19. i am i i am 19.
i just mean i haven't planned out how to
become um economically successful as an
as an artist again you're 19. give
yourself some time nobody but it's
evident to me by listening to you speak
about what you'd like to do and and what
you're into
that's a reflection to me on on how
you were probably properly loved by your
family
yeah because you're able you're able to
focus on these things that might move
you your life your career forward yeah
rather than so many of the people i've
interviewed or just lost in trying to
survive yeah and you're thriving yeah i
that is something i'm very grateful for
yeah you should be and and also kind of
connected to that i think also want to
like i said keep like teaching and
working with with young people and kids
you don't you don't hear people speak
like that 19 year olds speak like that
unless they're
properly raised no that is that is i
think something i can definitely
attribute to my
to my parents and my upbringing i really
want to because i've worked at like this
circus camp that my dad actually started
like 35 years ago in middletown it's
like a children's circus
summer program that's just like a
five-week
day camp type thing that leads up to
like a big
performance with puppets and card paper
mache huge paper mache props and stuff
but i for the last three years i've
worked there i was a counselor but then
this last summer i kind of like got
promoted to like a teaching artist
position and i was teaching
improv and clowning and i was helping
teach juggling because
juggling is something i've learned when
i was like eight there and teaching
improv to these kids
was like just such an incredible
experience because
i it like first showed me the amount of
creativity that like the improv is an
incredible thing regardless yeah for
adult anyone yeah and i'm i'm not the
best improv teacher yet i think next
summer i'm probably gonna have a lot
more improv teaching skills than i did
last summer
but uh
it it just it also showed me like
it made me very hopeful because
i saw that these kids
even though they have their struggles
and their conflicts
like they're growing up in a world
that has a little bit more understanding
and like
communication
than maybe i did or anyone before me
like they're they're getting these
things and through like the education
that they're getting and access to the
access to things that they have
they're growing up with just a little
bit of a head start even though they're
growing up into a world that is
really conflicted and like
confused
but
they're growing up with more tools than
i feel like i had when i was growing up
and a lot of other people from my
generation before had so it made me
really hopeful and it just made me want
to keep
working with kids honestly yeah that's
great
what's the
you're not you're only 19. but what's
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
or what do you what do you keep
reminding yourself to live by
i think
it's it's probably presence at least
that's the most like useful
reminder that i've i've had and worked
on it's still something that i'm working
on very much but i i think a lot about
the future and the past constantly
and bringing myself to the present is
probably the most
useful thing as like a human and as an
artist that i can do and and also
connecting my my mind and my body i
think is also something that i
want to keep practicing and has been
like incredibly useful new york city is
a great place to remind yourself of how
the past
in the future
and the president are all connected yeah
i found that just walking down certain
streets in new york city you know that
there's some great history on this block
yeah no i the history of every single
place is like
kind of baffling to me like washington
square park
there's so much incredible history
there's so many
artists who made their start there
musicians stand-up comedians
there's like there's like terrifying
things that have happened there also
like there's been lynchings there and
like far in the past new york is such a
great history terrible history it's
incredible like terrible and incredible
yeah
yeah like the entirety of america you
can't you can't escape
you can't escape death and murder in the
past and like horrible atrocities but
you also can't escape like
the most incredible beautiful things
that are beautiful things everywhere
yeah yeah
all right rowan thank you so much for
talking with me and i wish you the best
of luck with school and everything else
thank you very much thank you
you